Speaker 1: Oh, man. Where to even start with this?
Candace Owens has proudly and defiantly come
out against museums, against museums. We have
long spoken about the anti-intellectual
and pseudo intellectual leanings of the
American right wing. They used to sort of
couch them in a more, Oh, what's the word?
I don't want to say more defensible, but compared
to now, a slightly more defensible way. But now
it is just completely overt. These are really
pathetic people and they are playing to the lowest
common denominator. A huge swath of the American
right wing doesn't read, doesn't think critically,
has no media literacy skills, and they just want
their beliefs spoon fed to them by Fox News and
people like Candace Owens and Ben SHAPIRO and
others, and in order to keep them in that state.
Right wing influencers like Candace Owens have
started to make them feel proud and confident in
their beliefs that books are bad, learning is bad,
museums are bad. And here is a segment of Candace
Owens talking about how she's actually very
anti museum. Take a look at this next question.
Speaker 2: What are your thoughts on the British
Museum and their artifacts from other cultures?
They have returned, many of them, to Nigeria.
Do you think they should return them all? JENSEN
You know, I actually kind of hate a lot of museums
because they steal our tax dollars. And so, yeah,
defund all the museums and send back all
the artifacts. The amount of money that
was given in the COVID bill, the trillions of
dollars, all of it going to like the Kennedy
Center and the African American Museum. And
what do they do with that? Sit on the board,
take all the money. It's kind of become this
huge money laundering operation. And yeah,
I say return it all. If you want to see
something, it's got to go to the country,
you know? So I'm actually totally fine with
that because only because I'm very anti museum.
Because they stole a lot of our money. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Interestingly, she pronounces museum
Museum, which was. But the only two people I know
that do that are former producer Louis and Candace
Owens. Years ago we were wondering where did Lewis
get this museum pronunciation? Maybe. Maybe he and
Candace Owens went to that same ritzy school
in Connecticut, right? No. In all seriousness,
this is the type of thing that many right
wing and Republican voters consider fresh
and interesting and sort of on the vanguard
of thinking. The modern Republicans love this
stuff. And her idea is go to the country, right?
I mean, if you want to see historical artifacts
like Egyptian mummies and Roman statues and Greek
pottery, just go to the countries. It's just lying
around there. You can just see it. Or if you want
to see, you know, artwork from famous artists,
whether it's the Mona Lisa or, you know, Van Gogh,
Starry Night or whatever, go to the countries,
whatever that means. If you want to see important
documents like the Magna Carta or the Gutenberg
Bible or whatever, go to the country, whatever
the hell that means. This is part of a bigger
movement that includes clips like this.
This is Andrew Tate explaining why he is
above reading books. He's above it. He's too
good or too smart or too strong or whatever.
Speaker 3: Reading books is a very cheap
way to, I guess, entertain. I wouldn't
call it entertainment because my brain is
far too advanced. I'm too smart to read,
right. To sit there. No smart people read. Now
I need action. I need constant chaos. I have
to feel content. I need to be driving a supercar
and I'm fighting fucking a bunch of hose champagne
and going crazy. I can't just sit there. Oh.
Speaker 1: Why would you read a book when you
can have champagne going crazy, just exploding
explosive champagne all over the place,
not going to be bothered with a book.
Speaker 3: And the pirate on the
boat like it is for people with slow brains.
Speaker 1: Right. So this is now. Now, by the way,
do I do I even really need to mention, by the
way. It actually takes more brainpower. And
it's so fraught to use the term intelligence. It
requires lots of brainpower to actually go and get
the information out of a book rather than sitting
there with explosive champagne watching reality
TV. Now, I have no problem with TV or any of it,
Right? I watch TV. I watch shows Kaleidoscope on
Netflix right now, by the way. Really good, you
know. But the idea of books or for the lesser
thinkers sort of thing is part of the same.
I'm against museums or museums or whatever
pronunciation you choose. And this is all either
with Candace Owens. I believe it's deliberate
with Andrew Tate. I think it's not. I think he's
just kind of stumbling across nonsense. Part of it
is make the people that follow you feel good about
just getting all of their beliefs from you without
thinking about them too much. Without reading,
Without learning. Without looking at alternative
sources. They benefit from people thinking books.
Now. Not for me, folks. We are in a crisis on
YouTube. Something is happening on YouTube where
our channel and others like ours appear to be
getting deprioritized by some kind of algorithm.
I will have more information about this when I
have it. Please remember like the video. Leave a
comment. Hit the subscribe button. It's really the
it's free and everybody can do it and it will help
us at youtube.com slash The David Pakman Show.